لديك أمل في أن تتخذ الأمم المتحدة
موقفا هنا نعتقد أنه من الضروري أن
تتخذ الأمم المتحدة موقفا أه أكثر من 80
دولة رعت القرار
الذي يدعو ببساطة إلى وقف
إطلاق النار لأسباب إنسانية كما يحث على إطلاق سراح
الرهائن جميع الرهائن أه هو  عندما
وقفت الأمم المتحدة على مسؤوليتها
تصرفت وفقا
للقانون الدولي وتحركت فعلا لمنع
قتل مذبحة المدنيين في
غزة وتدمير سبل
عيشهم أه نأمل أه ونحث
جميع أه أه شركائنا في
مجلس الأمن على  صوتوا لهذا القرار
لأن الرسالة إذا لم يفعلوا
فهي مجرد تأييد لما
تفعله إسرائيل وما تفعله إسرائيل هو
أه ببساطة قتل الناس وتدمير سبل
عيشهم أه حرمانهم من الطعام
والماء يعرض للخطر أه أه
أمن الجميع  المنطقة تقوض
مصالح حلفائها في الجزء الخاص بنا
من العالم بإيذاء شعبها
من خلال المساهمة في بيئة
ستحرم فيها شعبها من
العيش في سلام. وقد حاولت الولايات المتحدة
تشجيع إسرائيل على ممارسة ضبط النفس
في غزة و  لقد وضعت الولايات المتحدة مبادئ
توجيهية أه لما ستبدو عليه غزة بعد الحرب
لا تهجير قسري
للناس لا إعادة احتلال من قبل إسرائيل لا
حصار أو حصار لا تقليص في
الأراضي هذه فكرة المنطقة العازلة
داخل غزة لا استخدام غزة كمنصة
للإرهاب كما  حسنًا، هذه
خطوط حمراء وأنت ترى الضغط الآخر الذي تمارسه
الولايات المتحدة لضبط النفس من
وجهة نظرك هو تجاهل إسرائيل لهذه
الخطوط الحمراء تمامًا أه إسرائيل تجاهلت
كل واحد من تلك الخطوط الحمراء
بالفعل 1.9 مليون فلسطيني في غزة
نزحوا هذا  حوالي 85% من
سكان غزة أه يدمر
كل جزء من غزة الذي يذهب إليه
انظر إلى الشمال لماذا تقوم إسرائيل
بتجريف الشوارع لماذا تدمر
المنازل الفارغة إنها ببساطة تخلق
بيئة ستكون
غير صالحة للسكن لذلك  نعم امريكا طلبت
ذلك اسرائيل تحدت امريكا تحديت
القانون الدولي تحديت مصلحة
الجميع في المنطقة والسؤال
هو ماذا لو استمرت اسرائيل
بذلك أه هل سيكون الموقف الموحد هو
ما سنفعله جميعا لذلك  هل
حصلت على أي ضمانات هل حصل
الأردن على أي تأكيدات من
المسؤولين الأمريكيين بأنه سيطبق
تلك الخطوط الحمراء التي ما زلنا نجريها في
محادثة مع الولايات المتحدة؟ سوف نلتقي
بوزير الخارجية في غضون
ساعتين إلى جانب  زملاء آخرون أه من
الواضح أه متفقون معنا
بشأن تلك المبادئ التي
نختلف فيها عندما يتعلق الأمر بالمطالبة بوقف
إطلاق النار، نحن فقط لا نرى أي مبرر
لعدم الحث على وقف إطلاق النار هذا هو
الصراع الأول الذي ترى فيه
جدلاً حول مدى إلحاح الأمر  وقف
القتال حتى تسمح للدبلوماسية
بالبدء في العمل أعني ما الذي يمكن أن يبرر
أن هناك فقط أنه من
غير المنطقي حقًا أن نكون صادقين أه أه لا
أحث أه على إنهاء العدوان
الذي يخلق الظروف على على
أساس
غير مقبول من قبل أي ضمان قانوني سمها ما شئت